on Thursday conspiracy theorist and
radio host
Alex Jones was ordered to stop selling
fake cures for the corona virus
Jones has been Hawking toothpaste and
other items he calls a stop gate against
the pathogen New York's Attorney General
called the claims a serious threat to
America's well-being but Jones
questionable side business is far from
unique catherine herridge joins us with
more on how some people are taking
advantage in a time of fear Catherine
good morning
well thank you Dan and good morning The
Secret Service took our CBS News team
inside their global operations center
here in Washington the tracks
transnational crimes cyber criminals are
opportunists who hijacked major news
events for financial gain and koban 19
is no different cyber criminals are
taking advantage of a weary public the
scam started with a simple Google search
for medical masks websites like this one
ensnare victims by offering hard to get
medical supplies for outrageous prices
you can see here that they the total
cost of masks it was five thousand and
five thousand dollars five thousand
dollars and they were requesting payment
up front CBS News got exclusive access
to this global operation center where
the Secret Service is tracking the spike
in coronavirus cybercrime anytime
there's a heightened element of fear
such as with the corona virus criminals
are going to exploit that if you get an
email like this what are the red flags
they requested Western Union monogram
board bitcoin is forms of payments
legitimate business will offer payments
either through invoicing or through
credit cards
hackers are also mimicking legitimate
government agencies this email claiming
to be from the World Health Organization
promises safety tips agents are urging
the public to be on alert for
misspellings bad grammar and not to open
attachments if you don't know the sender
thread actors are going to take
advantage of the situation and milk it
for all that it's worth Adam Meyers with
the tech security firm CrowdStrike says
cyber criminals are working all of the
angles there are plenty of threat actors
that will use phone scams as well how
does that work they will call up they'll
know a lot about you and that will kind
of build that trust and then you kind of
follow the instruction always call back
and make sure that it's something that's
with more people working from home in
the weeks ahead the Secret Service says
the risk will only increase because most
home computers don't have the same
security features as a company network
Michelle the important information
Catherine thank you I just it still
boggles my mind how people come up with
these ideas to scam folks and in times
of crisis yeah well yeah it's terrible
we said earlier we see the best in
people in times of crisis unfortunately
it seems like we've seen the worst as
well in some and it's easy to say it's
common sense to avoid these things but
some people get fooled and that's why
they're anxious that's why these folks
are good at doing this because they know
they can do people